i'm especially proud of the six
extraordinary men we've assembled this
year particularly because they come from
mysterious faraway lands two are from
canada one is from scotland
one is from britain one is from long
island and another one is from an exotic
place called chuck
please show them you love them long time
when i introduce them to you first up
he was a model he starred in eastenders
then he got a pretty sweet gig on true
blood and now he's set to play a dead
morally corrupt sheriff who comes back
to life in the body of a rich
bioengineer only on tv ladies and
gentlemen
the star of fox's new drama the
frankenstein code rob kaczynski
all right many folks including our own
magazine actually thought this
canadian-born actor was english what are
you doing rob
oh rob you're a little part of here okay
this one
it even had my name and i didn't figure
it out
all right uh many folks thought this
canadian actor was actually english
because he pulls off this superior
accent as felix dawkins on orphan black
at 25 he's the youngest member of our
panel but no less brave and no less
warriorish jordan guevaras
i love you too hello did i find the
right seat oh thank god
all right this guy has a resume custom
made for comic-con he starred in dark
angel
lost
x-men origins the mortal instruments
real steel and now he plays the
exterminator vasily fett in fx drama the
strain say hi to kevin durant
all right he studied his art at the
royal scottish academy of music and
drama and he was once nominated for a
lawrence olivier award for most
promising performer in 2003 but we just
love him because he looks damn hot in a
kilt
all right here's
okay this actor coming up he strikes me
as that dude in high school
he wasn't the quarterback he wasn't the
asb president but not because he
couldn't do it just because he didn't
need to do it because he was so damn
cool people were automatically drawn to
his magnetic personality and his
incredible good looks he's the star of
heroes reborn zachary levi
hall h i'm in you
finally a truly great actor who also
happens to star on a truly great show
he plays abraham ford the incomparable
michael cudlitz
this is for my wife
two redheads get it on
i gotta ask you first did you all know
each other how do you how do you is this
not the first time you've all met
correct
uh we're meeting for the first time but
i i knew kevin and jordan and rob and
michael
because you know we play poker and stuff
together i don't know it feels like
we're getting the old team back together
i should have an outfit and
i feel a sitcom it feels a little bit
like you know when a boy band gets back
together yeah 20 years after they
probably should have retired
i'm that boy band member who's very
obviously about a foot shorter than
everybody else
and looks so don't worry we'll take care
of it
now i apologize i realize this is a very
chic question
but when you were packing for comic-con
did you take a moment to fix god what
what do i wear do i do i am i'm worried
about looking too much like a hipster
but i don't look like i'm trying too
hard and i don't want to look too stiff
but i don't look like a you know a slob
does this go through your mind who are
you aiming this act
no
i don't know all right it's a trick
question luckily my wife dresses me yeah
so she's
cause all the wives out there thank you
for taking care of us and showing what
uh direction we should walk in and what
we should say exactly how to comb our
hair and tell us to brush our teeth at
night thank you i love you
i dress myself and i love mass effect so
n7 thank you
i just tried to not look 12.
that was my aim and thank you
entertainment weekly for putting me on
the panel with the would-be hollywood
linebackers
i would like to see some arm curls with
you later that'd be cool
all right in case some of the fine folks
in the audience were unable to catch any
of your shows uh please
update me on the most badass thing you
did at work in the last year
i'm gonna start with you
i can't well i can't tell you the most
badass things that we just did it about
a week ago
um
yeah why not there's only a few of us
you won't tell anyone right
they won't
but last year they we had a scene at the
construction site uh
where i went uh
as the fans have called it abe [ __ ]
on uh on about
17 or 18 walkers so
zack
um
yeah i mean i don't know i don't know
what i'm even allowed to talk about
without a sniper's like red dot on my
forehead right now um
we i i killed some people
that may or may not deserve it i don't
know uh but it was
i've been felt pretty badass at the time
let's just say i unloaded an entire clip
of like 16 rounds in one scene and
nice very it was pretty fun that was
pretty kick-ass
that's impressive we don't even have
guns but uh yeah i'm we're building up
to ours uh if we're keeping this like
you know warriors and stuff and beating
people up and uh i beat up a few people
but at the end of the season which we
haven't filmed yet there's the biggest
battle that happened pretty much in
scotland at the time and uh it's sort of
um
it is the end of scottish history or the
highland culture so we're yet to film
that and i think i get to kill a few
people yeah it's gonna be good
awesome yeah can you just can you just
keep talking for a while
it really is beautiful
i'm just saying
i'm in love here
but you can talk too that's good
it's the accents yeah
what is your accent it's [ __ ] new
jersey sorry i'm not supposed to
curse apparently there's sir uh please
be advised that the members of the
audience may be under 18 years of age
which means i'm not supposed to curse
i actually think it means i just can't
draft you yet
all right mr dredd what was the uh your
kick-ass moment this year uh there was a
lot of kick-ass moments um
uh i think the most kick-ass thing about
my character on the strain is that when
he has
tons of automatic weapons available to
him and
bombs and grenades he chooses
to kill all those damn vampires with his
bare hands
with my rebar
and uh
i think that uh you know when i watch
this character i'm like i wish i could
grow up and be like that guy and you
know because i would be running away
from those damn vampires
but yeah it's the rebar killing
what do you think jordan do you think
you can live up to that i mean i mean
what served a lot of tea this season it
seems like that was i gave someone a
makeover
but it was a badass makeover actually
though hang on i strapped on a very
fancy coat and i kicked in the door
okay nice
thank you guys i really appreciate that
this feels like high school all over
again
what why
what did you who did you kill thank you
a lot of people to be fair mostly the
alliance
i
i've killed i killed so many uh i did
one very cool thing
i'm not actually allowed to talk about
it
no i got to i did get to wield the doom
hammer which is uh
uh i play a very very badass character
in warcraft which is coming out
um
and he has a very very mythical mystical
very famous weapon called the doomhammer
which is
it's like a hammer that
makes doom
and
i got to seriously like kill some
serious people with that thing that was
fun in motion capture form as well so it
wasn't even real so wait just to recap
we have um
murderers are bound you killed murder
murder murder murder makeover
fancy pants but he murdered those smokey
eyes guys
he he killed that suit he's on our team
we
you know
one of us
15 year old me is just dying right now
hold on we got a guy who kills zombies
we got a guy who
fights superheroes i i'm assuming i'm
just gonna i'm not you're not outside we
can't talk about the terminology
and we got we got a guy who killed other
english people
vampires yeah a guy who kills
not allowed to say
and
and a man who slays
i know it takes a lot of dedication and
hard work to become a warrior
but nobody exits their mama's womb
looking and acting like mel gibson from
braveheart so i want you to travel back
to your complicated youth
if you had to write your own diary of a
wimpy kid
what would have been your first entry
i'm going to start with you well i i was
i
i almost started with you jordan that
was really bad that's okay
that was so bad of me i'm gonna go with
kevin you can win this round i know
it's not a competition
you want to start with me yeah yeah
we'll start with the yeah yeah um
yeah i remember i was in um uh junior
kindergarten and i was about six foot
three
and all the other children thought that
i was the incredible hulk
and they all would pile on me
and be like oh he's gonna explode off at
some point he's gonna explode us off
we're all gonna go flying and uh
the teachers all removed all the other
kids and i was on the bottom crying
and then and then um i beat everyone up
in that school after that
no
um yeah so
becoming a warrior especially becoming a
hero because for my career i've played a
lot of
horrible horrible men i'm this year i'm
finally
playing hero warriors so uh thank you uh
industry for letting me uh
save the day as opposed to eat a lot of
children
rob what kind of kid were you rob
ugly one mainly i think um but now i i i
really thought and the thing about this
is she said i've been thinking about
this a lot trying to think about when
in my life i was not a brave warrior and
all i keep thinking about is i mean even
up until last week
i watch any movie or even like an aspc a
ad with like you know sarah mclachlan's
and i'm weeping like a child yeah
i i mean i've seen lion king like 30
times
like long live the king no
i we i i ugly cried at green mile i mean
snot bubbles i'm like this close to the
tv just like
but that's part of it that's part of the
i cried during futurama i watched
futurama the other day and i cried i
think that's part of being the warrior
what yeah empathy
is that a thing
i don't know i mean i hope it is because
then i'm like
right there would ya that's why my dad
eats turkey hearts at thanksgiving he's
trying to absorb the power of the turkey
that's why my father eats the hearts of
newborn children
it's a thing though turkey hearts are
not isn't that a thing
he's mediterranean they do a lot of very
bizarre things
on holidays all right jordan you talk
about when you're a kid i was such a
troublemaker
but not because i was mischievous or
because i wanted to get in trouble i was
constantly fighting for the underdog i
was the underdog
that's the real hero
no i was oh
yeah
i was not the underdog i was just a
quiet kid i was not a i was the thinking
i've played a lot of thinking heroes
thinking warriors
people who use i don't know their their
intellect to try and outwit the enemy
please god let that be a thing too oh my
god
what about you
wow uh this is like the first warrior
that i've played i guess but i know
going back to childhood i i remember
there was a girl in my class i
fancied and we had this game called kiss
cuddle or torture
oh yeah very popular scottish game and
uh that alert
what are the rules are they well you
basically i don't think you want to ask
really
yeah if you get caught you get a choice
and um
i'm going i'm going right to torture
i don't know i mean yeah scalding's a
great place to grow up send your kids
there
and uh yeah the girl i fancied for for
many years she was chasing me and i was
thinking yeah i'm gonna let her catch me
at some point catch me and uh i i i was
looking behind me watching her chase me
and i walked i ran right into a wall uh
and knocked myself out
and woke up with a big scar on my knee
and uh yeah she never chased me again oh
so oh this
was pretty heroic there was no kiddle
kiss cuddle there was another kiss
yeah so i guess the moral is
don't play those kind of games
any of you want to chase him now
zachary take us back take take us back
to the levi youth
are you sure you want to go there oh i
want to um uh i i don't know i was a
spaz i was uh
that was an absolute spaz so a lot has
changed uh
i i played a ton of video games and read
comic books and would like literally run
outside and pretend to be gambit when my
when all of my when all of my other
friends wanted to be wolverine and i was
like counter culture counterculture
charge card charge card charge card boa
um
and uh
thank you
but i would but i you know i and i was
uh i just liked entertaining people i
was i was a little spazzy actor kid i
did theater since i was yay big and then
when i realized that wow that can and i
was teased incessantly like i i thought
the cool thing to do in class would come
up with like sketches and like spoof uh
i would like spoof songs like weird al
wood but not nearly as good and didn't
have cool videos to back it up and my
teachers like in sixth grade thought oh
he's creative let's let him do that in
front of all the cool kids in my class
and so i would be like watch this guys
and i had no friends so um
but but they encouraged my creativity
and then that kind of led to i don't
know growing up and realizing that you
got to own who you are and then i found
out that you can actually be a spaz and
get paid for it so thank you for having
me nice yeah
all right what about you mister
uh growing up i was tiny i was i i
wrestled for two years there was a 98
pound weight class i sung soprano in the
choir
not centered but
can we just stop for a moment and admire
how red my hair is
so red
it is bloody red
in fuego it's redder on what i'm looking
at than what you guys are looking at
bright red
that's not that bad
uh soprano in the choir not not tenor
full-on soprano
um
and i was in the band and i was i play
trombone because we all know that when
you get out of school and you go to you
know events you can just pull out the
trombone and
i play trombone as well yeah what like
the the possibly the most useless
instrument unless you're
going for a career in trombone and you
get bullied when you're walking home or
yeah exactly exactly big old truck you
know you don't show up at a party
sometimes at a christmas party and
someone happens to have a trombone
laying
around ridiculous
um
and drama you know and i just uh i don't
know i guess i guess the only thing
that's that that is that could be sort
of
transferable or correlates with growing
up is always i'd always had a very
strong sense of
what was right and wrong
whichever you choose is up to you as
long as you know what it is that you're
choosing and as a kid i always i always
knew what right and wrong was and it
tends tended to lean to the right
or the correctness um but i was a little
you know
in in my day was a pus call it would you
will
all right that's it okay
let's move on all right at ew we have a
feature called uh watch this sorry about
that so we already know what to watch of
yours right now the great work that you
do now so now i want you to think that
that early role that you'd really rather
forget that you really want to apologize
to us all about
just want to use this time to say you
know should we ask the audience
we should be apologizing to them i
completely agree
uh what are we yeah i'm going to start
with you oh you're going to start with
me because i'm the loud mouth um i
uh i would say
oh gosh i don't know i mean i think
everything you do you still you
hopefully you pull fond memories from
and i cert i don't want to throw
anything under the bus because that's
what i feel like we're all being asked
to do right now but um
i would say
some of the more embarrassing moments
that i've had and something i've done i
did this movie called wieners um
and i don't know that that needs a lot
of explanation
uh but i'm going to explain anyway
because maybe it does need some
explanation it was it was me and fran
crans and keenan thompson and we we were
on this like
has anybody actually seen wieners
i'm you i'm guys
five people i rest my case
the movie michael the movie michael uh
can you repeat the question it was it
was a
it was a it was a buddy it was a buddy
comedy road trip movie keenan thompson
played a guy who uh
he applied to the oscar meyer wiener
company to drive one of their wiener
mobiles for like 10 years oh my god
and they kept denying i remember this
movie what year did you do that in thank
you
the guy who's all about warcraft
did you see my hammer of doomsayer
um what and uh what year was it is this
is this you in wieners that is
that was the embarrassing stuff so my
character and what we ran out of money
so i had to enter into this hot body
contest and uh
i
had to grease myself up
and like compete against these other
guys like male stripper kind of guys
and my producers and my producers came
to me
are you showing them can they see yeah
i've never seen anything like just get a
little can then get up to his
could you do the pose again
yeah there it is
your smile a couple yeah so i had a wax
i had to i had to grease my whole body
my producers basically came to me and
said so listen for this for this scene
we're gonna need you to wax your whole
body
and i'm not a not hairy guy and so it
took four and a half hours to wax my
whole body and it was and it was the
most painful thing i've ever been
through and i it gave me some i
commiserate with the ladies out there
who might who might do anything but even
like i was like this is death this is
death i don't ever want to do this ever
again ever so that's uh so there you go
so no wieners too then no wieners
actually i think the working title was
weinerd i think that was uh
rob what about you you got something you
want to say you're sorry for i've got
nothing well there is plenty i want to
say sorry for uh in terms of
i i i've tried to be proud of everything
i've done i i wouldn't apologize for
anything i've done i will however take
this moment to apologize for my
australian accent in pacific rim
i swear to god i can do an australian
accent
i just didn't do it in that film
everyone in australia whenever anyone
comes to us from australia and they oh
you're in that movie you were that good
film you were terrible i know
so if i could take anything back it
would be just maybe just work a little
harder do you want to demonstrate now
that you can pull it off
not particularly
come on mate let's go for it
oh
it's been laid brother because that was
really good
it's rubbish
i lived in new zealand for a year so i i
feel like i've got a good grasp on an
australian accent but i i just ruined it
for that film i mean it really and i
watch it back and go
like it just didn't sound like that when
i was saying it i promise and i'm really
sorry
in advance i do know you don't have to
keep telling me on twitter that i did a
rubbish australian accent i know it
wasn't good but the film was all right
apology accepted
mr durant how about you anything
anything um i would like to apologize um
for a show called once upon a time that
i did monday through friday
mondays wednesdays and fridays
i played pinocchio a singing pinocchio a
six foot six singing pinocchio and on
tuesdays and thursdays i subbed in for
aladdin
and um
it just kind of didn't look right i
googled this it's not the abc's no this
is not the abc once upon a time no no
this although
this is the uh this is the ontario place
in toronto my first paying gig i got
paid 40 a day to do three shows a day
and um a lot of kids were terrified to
see such a ginormous pinocchio
and then they were like okay there's no
one buying tickets go outside and try to
bring people in and i think i made many
many children cry
and the sweeter i try to be
it just didn't work what did you have to
sing
uh
let's begin at the beginning with once
upon a time and then it was just like
this scary thing
pinocchio
dance thing
and um i know probably none of you have
seen it but uh
it was before youtube
um but uh
i'll be doing the show later on
forty dollars a ticket
forty dollars a ticket though that's it
that's it
all right michael what about you
oh
it's probably it's a list
uh i did a movie years ago called live
virgin
oh and uh
it was
just like a romeo and juliet type thing
mobster and porn industry guy
one of them had his son wanted a
daughter anyway
i played a gay porn star
which they insisted we go do research on
naturally
honest to god true story so
ron jeremy was going to take us on to a
set
uh don't worry i i just ate i get it
it's not going to get bad too bad
um so
apparently the men who work in the
industry don't get paid like the women
so they have a lot of straight men going
to gay porn because that's where they
make the money
this story's not going to end well
um
what else
no not really so i i
i this is what we're sorry about right
um so
we were invited onto a set and
we watched
uh people work
uh yeah i'll be careful
and they were doing this particular
scene and my wife had said to me she
says when you get home
you're not coming anywhere near me
all right that's fair
so i go and i'm watching these people
work
and i watch this guy work
for about two and a half hours
wow
yeah
that's some research right there i don't
think i came near my wife for about
two and a half weeks after that
because i could not
even
partially replicate let me back up it
was not gay porn that we went to go see
i couldn't even come close
to what that guy did at work
which
was supposed to translate into my
leisure time
and somewhere floating out there is a
picture of me
well a film of me
running around in daisy dukes
you can't find it on the phone you can't
i'm i'm i'm sure i'm giving you a moment
i don't think you want to google this
work
he's working on it down there and work
boots and
a leather vest
change your mind i do want to google
this
i can't wait until i'm your age and i
have so much to be sorry about
i'm 25. i haven't i i haven't messed up
that badly yet
like i'm sure it's coming don't get me
wrong i'm a screw-up i'm sure it's down
the pipeline don't worry
it's going to be something really bad
trust me every one of these stories
you're hearing when we got that call you
got the job we were like yeah of course
yeah
that's it all the
that's what makes the shame really stick
exactly
all right one last sam what about you is
this oh
god i can't follow that that's
priceless
um i i i did a film that hopefully will
never see the light of day i not that
you know it was terrible i really
uh enjoyed myself on it but it was
called young alexander the great from
macedonia
and uh i met the lovely lauren cohen
who's in the walking dead
yes uh so i've made some of my best
friends there on the show but yeah it
was horrendous everyone had this stomach
bug we were filming in egypt and uh
every day it was just filled with uh
very unhappy uh british actors all
sweating and running to the toilet every
five minutes
oh so don't go see it i'll still take
that over michael's experience
okay
i'm gonna look it up
all right unlike women
men really aren't ever asked if and when
they've ever been treated like a piece
of meat
when was the last time you experienced
sexism in the workplace
just five seconds ago backstage i
already apologize for that
we all want to apologize
wait oh my god i feel great about myself
right now
thank you guys
what happened backstage
uh i know literally nothing i was lying
like
rob you want to start i know you want to
start um
i mean yeah it does happen i'm not going
to lie that i haven't been put in some
really awful positions but
i remember when i was first starting out
and i was a and literally i i had done
barely anything and a very very very
very
immensely powerful figure in the
industry
um
asked me to do some charity work with
them and uh and i did i i
i do a lot of that and i was happy to do
more and uh
after that i was put in some very very
uncomfortable awkward positions and i
kept on being like dude look i'm
i'm not i'm not interested in that i'm
just let's just be friends you know i
don't want to be rude but and and they
would put me in circles where you know
they'd introduce you to agents they'd
introduce you to
superstars from around the world and
they'd be like this can be your life if
you do this and it
it went on for a long time and it was
it was complete harassment and if you
know
i understand the fear that people have
about coming forward about something
like that because especially as a man
you feel like you should be able to
handle the situation like that but when
you're a young kid
in this industry yeah
you often can't
with me it culminated in me finally
going okay and going over to the house
and then grabbing that person by the
neck
and saying if you ever contact me again
i'm gonna break this
oh and i was 22 then
and bigger than i am now so
it was yeah it was
horrifying i've never let myself get put
into that position again but it was
actually terrifying to see how easily it
happened
and it happens
every day
over and over and i'd be very surprised
if everybody on this panel hasn't had a
similar experience with somebody mm-hmm
kevin whatever try to do that you're
nodding
i feel left out
um
i don't know if people are just scared
of me or i i
my my experience was through
um the young lady that i moved to
hollywood with
and this fella uh said he was a manager
and he was gonna
you know turn her into
a big old star and uh
and he took her out to dinner
and um he started to explain to her that
he could only represent her
if if he was hot for her
and then
he put some money across the table
and then he said that his
car was in the parking lot
and uh
and she she she um
she came home and she was really hurt by
it and uh
i completely
lost my mind um
and i called him up
and uh
i never heard from him again and neither
did she
uh because um
you know i just i just didn't want him
talking to her anymore i mean this is
something that happens all the time it
doesn't happen to giant uh sasquatches
like myself very often
but
be my friend
but yeah i i experienced it through
someone else's um you know perspective
but i feel like it can be more pervasive
do you know what i mean like it we
always when we think of sexism
immediately we think of sexual
harassment but i feel like it's way more
pervasive than that and it's it's
very subversive and it's tricky with
blackmail
in other ways and it's also and not just
in a sense of sexual exploitation but
like the mythology of the man that men
are either manly or they're not there's
no
there's no wiggle room in terms of
gender like if you were to make a list
of all the qualities that men have and
women have no person in life
would completely conform to one side of
the list there's always some crossover
but there's a pressure to be a certain
way look a certain way act a certain way
and
it's it i think it's it's
it's just silly it's really silly and i
also feel like
thanks
and
yeah i think the mythology of the man is
just ridiculous it's got to stop and
that's another thing that that hollywood
in particular is really bad in terms of
sexism is really bad about exploiting
and um i don't know i just think there
needs to be more room for men
all different kinds of men men who or
not just men
non-binary gender
um it like the whole i don't know if
anybody's familiar with like the
cisgender stuff but it's not just about
being a cisgendered man it's about being
a fully multifaceted multi-dimensional
man and i think we need more of that i'm
looking to exploit more of that not just
the other
sam
sam what about you because i know that
the the gals have fun you know asking
you about you go commando under that
kilt but it does does it get to be a
little much when you you have to
answer those kind of questions all the
time um you know i think it's always in
ingest and uh i certainly you know don't
mind
a little bit of teasing or um fun but
you know sometimes you can get a little
too far and uh yeah next time i'll work
because it's productive too right
but yeah it can go too far i guess um
there have been occasions when
not myself but gray mctavish one of the
other uh fantastic actors on the show
he's he had a someone lying on the floor
trying to look up his kill and uh
i don't know i think this may be taking
a touch too far but um yeah it's uh
you know
in my perspective it's um a bit of fun
and i think uh
you know we just don't want to cross any
boundaries
i'm sorry i kind of made it heavy didn't
i no no it's because you know that comes
with the assumption that all men are
just constantly sexual always sexual
always looking for sex all the time
i think what you said absolutely like
you know the reason we're acting which
is a complete and utter lie
also as an addendum to that as well i i
mean i've had similar situations happen
with very powerful women too it's not
just you know
men aren't the only
perpetrators of this crime you know what
i mean it's just it's power that is the
perpetrator of this crime and those of
us who
you know have dreams find those dreams
exploited by people who can grant them
well and that's scary
yeah
hey if you have any questions for this
panel you uh want to talk about sexual
harassment maybe ask about porn we will
start lining up right now okay
i want to i want to lighten it up we got
to light it up yeah i mean i don't
understand how michael's thing isn't
sexual explicit exploitation in some way
oh gosh all right let me tell me tell me
about your most awkward or if it's not
awkward your sweetest fan encounter ever
awkward
or sweet fan encounter let me start with
you
we we um we do these these conventions
um
on weekends i think probably mostly
everyone on the panels he probably had
an opportunity to do and if not i will
um where we meet fans that
not different than this which is more
one-on-one where we actually talk and
get signatures and photos and
there's this one
family that keeps visiting with their
their son justin and he has multiple
sclerosis
and
you can just
i
i can't explain what
how you see the light in this kid's eyes
when he
comes and visits us
and that that just transfers directly to
see that no matter what you're doing um
whatever the project is if it's if it's
some sort of history channel you know
biopic which is you know teaching
history changing lives or it's some sort
of throwaway would we think
entertainment just fluff you we
we have the opportunity to affect lives
in ways that we we're not even aware of
when it happens and when you see that
come back to you in the form of somebody
coming to visit you
and from something that
you have done or you are a part of
you're able to bring that much joy and
affect them in in that way my you know
i'm sitting here talking about some some
kid that no one knows if you turn around
you look look at this hall this hall is
full of 7 000 people
who are affected by what we are doing up
here for you and every panel that's been
here today
um yeah that's huge
yeah thank you thank you so much yes for
for that because it's
it's it's about you guys
um
it happened it happens often and it's
just there's there's so many moments
when
when when it comes back to us and uh
it's we're very very all of us are very
grateful for it zachary what about you
any awkward or sweet fan moment
fan encounter um
i mean look i'm sure yeah there's a lot
of awkward
ones and there's a lot of sweet ones um
but i i just want to kind of keep
running on what what michael was saying
because i
it's you know the arts is a very
interesting thing i think that you know
there are a lot of other vocations in
the world where it's a you know you pay
for a service the service is done and
it's very clear that it mission has been
accomplished you pay a plumber to come
and you know fix your plumbing and
you pay them you and the plumbing is
fixed it's it's a very clear-cut kind of
linear thing
uh and the plumber knows that their
service has been done or whatever you
know um but in the arts you and
especially by the way when you're you
know theater's a little different
because you get a response immediately
and there's a symbiotic relationship
between you and your audience you know
if you're failing them i mean it's
pretty clear if they're not laughing at
the jokes if it's comedy if they're not
quiet if it's a drama and you people are
talking you know that you're not
connecting with them but television and
film are very interesting because you
make it kind of in a bubble and you
don't know
you don't ever you know unless you go to
conventions or you go to a fan meetup or
something you don't know how it's
affected somebody and
so
uh
so it's very
uh i think it's very important for us to
connect with fans i think it's very
important for us to hear that because
that is the feedback that we need to
have to in order for us to be better at
our craft and to know what we are
serving or not serving a certain
demographic and you know when somebody
comes up to you and they tell you that
you know when i for example when you
know when i was doing chuck and and
somebody told me that uh
rock and roll
i i love you guys um
uh but you know having fans come up and
and tell me that um
father had passed away a year before and
they hadn't seen their mom smile for a
year
and then they started watching chuck and
they started watching they started
seeing their mom smile and then the
whole family unit started getting
together and watching a television they
didn't really hang out normally
otherwise you know but there was this
one show that
brought them together and it moved them
and it meant something to them and
i mean that's what gives us as
entertainers as artists that's what
gives you purpose
it gives me purpose so
it's those moments that are the sweet
moments yeah
let's hear from some of those fans
because they they're waiting in line
let's start with you go ahead girl hi my
name is coco and my
question is coco you have a fan page
over here that's fantastic and by the
way i was there when the woman was on
the floor in front of graham
what but my question was you
last week i had an opportunity to drive
through new galloway
and looked at the landscape so when you
were younger and
obsessing or role-playing about king
arthur or robert the bruce how have you
brought that to the role of jamie fraser
i got this one um
what a great question
wow yeah that's uh see you're alluding
to i was brought up in the southwest of
scotland and uh
i am just very fortunate to be playing
this character that um is returned to
scotland and
um i've been away from scotland for uh
you know a good many years and so just
to rediscover you know my home country
to rediscover like the stories and music
and culture that that i grew up with but
didn't really appreciate at the time
because you're young and i guess that's
what we do as actors we you know we use
everything around us and and
um
and it's been uh really rewarding to go
back and hopefully sort of transfer that
across the screen so so you guys can
fall in love with the country as well
all right next girl
hello gentlemen i just want to say thank
you guys all are all amazing and thank
you entertainment weekly for bringing
such wonderful eye candy you're so
welcome thank you
don't take don't take offense
now that is sexism
and i liked it
my question is you know we're all here
all these diverse diverse people who
enjoy you know a certain thing like you
know star wars yeah or star trek yeah
game of thrones whatever it is what do
you guys come here for is there anything
that you like to geek out on
oh yes
buffy the vampire slayer oh yeah
i knew i knew that would get a reaction
it always does
buffy fringe
um
twin peaks
yes
everything i don't know the list is to
forever long i don't know exactly
mainly
i definitely want to get wienered next
year to go see that movie
there'll be a screening
an on-demand screening we could do a
double bill
feature
live virgin and weiner
rob rob what do you geek out about come
on oh man you know me i get get over
everything i mean i'm i was
i mean i'm a massive warcraft player i'm
i'm a massive i'm obsessed with star
trek i'm obsessed with mass effect i
like comics i mean i saw every episode
of chuck twice i mean
i i i this is i i i'm the lucky guy who
got to go from there to here this is i
i've been walking the floor for the last
two days spending hundreds of dollars my
favorite thing that happened actually
was i found a whole bunch of pacific rim
toys that i didn't have and i went and i
went oh how much is that and they went
aren't you in the film and i went yeah
and they went full price
i mean with that australian accent
now if you would have sounded better
i mean i love everything about comic-con
it's my favorite place in the world and
you know
there's a reason for that as the great
will wheaton
once said
wow and he paraphrased it he said being
a nerd is about loving what you love and
not apologizing for it yes and that's
what this is about we love what we love
and we love each other
we're here because we love walking dead
and we love everything zach does for
god's sake i mean we love outlanders and
the strain and orphan black and we love
star trek and star wars and we love
warcraft
and we like san diego it's okay all
right
let's sneak in another one okay dude in
the red shirt go oh cool i'm gonna do it
in rotterdam
now you're going first bro yeah
don't be able to play this do not be on
the landing party
don't worry i i i work captain i found
something interesting
it's poor guy so this is pretty cool
because uh my girlfriend and i totally
bonded over chuck
and southland
and
you got a strong girl there oh yeah so
pacific rim was the first action movie
we watched together so that was dope um
thanks for representing lefties
everywhere thanks that's awesome
my question is so as you guys do your
movies and your shows
what point do you decide you want to go
further with your stunt work and when
you drop the hard no on stuff
jordan let's start with you wow
did you say you'll start with me
i think i just hallucinated
i here's what i will say i have i
enjoyed kicking in that door so much
so much so rewarding was it to feel like
i had super powers
and because who doesn't want like let's
just be honest who doesn't want
superpowers of course i do
i would love to do more stunt work i
just have to find a vehicle for that um
my hiatus is from march
michael what about you talk about your
stuff um
not to kind of talk for everyone but i
think i'm gonna sort of talk for
everyone um i think we all wanna do as
much as we can at all times and we rely
on our stunt coordinators to pull us
back when it is not safe and we need to
realize that we
we are needed for the rest of the
episode the rest of the season the rest
of the movie the rest of our lives with
all of our body parts and our faces
intact and there are people who get paid
to take those risks and are good at
taking that risk and are so good at
taking that risk that their risk is
actually minimized
they keep us safe
we're going to push and try to do as
much as we can at all times because it's
fun
it's a blast
but you need to stay safe um so
you know agreed agree
all right and as i get older i want to
do less
have you ever said you could do
something to get the job and then go
there and be like i can't do it like
horse riding
yeah i can do that yeah yeah
fire burn arrow yeah easy australian
accent
it's never going away
poor rob okay next person go ahead
um hi my name is jill and i'm here with
my sister today karen hi jill hi karen
boy is that person behind you asleep
what is that
what the hell is that
do you see that oh my god i do but hey
you know what sometimes people need to
sleep through really entertaining panels
i'm sorry to interrupt go ahead um i was
cured
oh come on come on leave her alone
or him i don't know i can't tell
i was curious
what your dream role would be to play if
you are playing it or if there's
something out there you would like to
try to do
oh wow
barry allen or wally west for me
oh honest to god a country music star in
a biopic i don't know why oh that's
that's a good one conway twitty maybe
oh conway twitter
i don't know yeah that's not a good one
um
i can't think of any well i'm saying
like kenny chesney i don't want to play
kenny chesney
nobody wants to play kenny jenny chesney
kenny chesney doesn't want to leave
that's
hank williams what a great one yeah you
could be hank i would do that pretty
sure tom hiddleston just did that yeah i
think he did
kevin
my dream room yeah yeah um you know it's
it's really weird people ask me that i
don't really have a dream role i just um
uh to tell you the honest truth and it's
so cheesy and so corny
but every time i get a job it's it's
it's it's a dream role
it's like the the fact that i get
to bring life
uh to characters that and there's all
these uh
you know amazingly talented individuals
all around us that are helping us live
our dream as actors and we we actually
get to make stuff that you guys get to
watch and then you come to places like
this and you cheer for us
it's like the coolest damn thing i
couldn't have dreamt this up and so
every role that i get to play is my
dream role and i thank you for for for
watching everything and coming out and
doing it thank you
every answer after that is gonna suck
now
sam do you have a dream role oh god yeah
i i mean i want to go to space i want to
do something i wanted to be in aliens i
love those movies and that franchise
that's awesome uh i'd love to be in the
walking dead please that'd be very nice
thanks very much
we'll figure something out make it
happen
i'll bring the accent
i got to get the chick with the book on
her head go
what do you got there
hello oh my
great balance that's stuck on you no
oh wow
that's magic
so
well done
so my name is megan and um i'm an artist
and jordan you play a wonderful artist
in orphan black thank you and i just
wanted to know what's your favorite
artist cause mine is andy warhol and
jackson pollock
that's so funny you would ask me this
question
um i know so little about art but
but
um i had someone i i was talking with
someone about what i would like to do
for season four and
um this person gave me a couple of harsh
criticisms and one of which was that she
really didn't believe that i knew
anything about art and that i was an
artist and that yeah it was tough
but
she gave me some really great advice
which was
that i should bring all of because i'm
not a visual artist i tried once and i
burned that canvas it does not exist
anymore it was so bad i don't know what
i was attempting to do cubism or
something it was awful
but acting um
isn't is a form of impressionist or
expressionist art it's it's both and the
artist that i happen to play is an
expressionist painter
so
if i take everything that i know about
my work as an actor and i i
bring it to this person then hopefully
more of that visual artistry will
register and some of that process has
been
just going into art shops like i was in
an art shop in dublin recently and i saw
all of these amazing local artists work
sketches like pencil drawings there's a
guy who sells
movie posters that he has drawn with
pencil crayons at the melrose trading
post in los angeles he's there every
sunday they're the most incredible i
bought two of them
um i haven't hung them up yet but i'm
just trying to expose myself to local
artists work so i don't have a name like
there are some artists that i really
love and uh architectural designers like
when i saw the basilica in italy it was
gorgeous
what am i saying what am i somebody cut
me off here i am okay i will i'll all i
can say is i will i'm i'm making an
effort to learn and educate myself more
about um
art history and and whatever i can
all right one more question
yay
sorry guys
nerd hq oh look at that um it's a
pleasure to spend uh this afternoon with
such intelligent talented and looking
warriors and moderator um also
hi zachary i love nerd hq i had the most
amazing time last year dancing the night
away at all your parties thanks i'm glad
i'm so glad
this girl knows how to start
question so about warriors um how some
sorry and a
of you have already answered this
question but for those who haven't uh
have any of you had any fight training
before getting your
um you know kick-ass-ness on on screen
and if any of you gotten into a fight
off screen
let's go with the off-screen part first
i'm gonna i'm gonna go on record here
saying that probably the english and
irish dudes on this panel have had more
fights than the american dudes on this
battle
sam what do you say what do you say sam
hi and we won every one of them
i was always
a bit of a as you guys call it a [ __ ] i
i uh
or or face
or pacifist to be honest when you're a
tall guy you probably had this as well
you know people don't tend to go for you
because you're tall and they think
you're pretty hard
i find that when i'm in a group being
the big guy in the group they always go
for me first well and if they've seen
your work too they're like oh yeah you
think you're a bad fussy guy no no no no
no no no no no
we left the accent thing a long time ago
we're past it
no but sarah i've had people come up to
me and say oh you think you know you
think you're a badass let's go
to which i say yeah let me buy you a
drink
yeah and it's over
yeah
no
it's not over pal
guys thank you so much
let's go out tonight let's go find
weiner go to
amazon.com thank you brave new world ew
bye everybody